vielleicht kennt der ein oder andere von
euch den untersberg bei beuys garten am
alpenrand ein ganz besonderer berg wenn
man den zahlreichen sagen und mythen
glauben schenken mag
in den meisten erzählungen geht es um
zeit löcher oder spiegel welten die
naturkräfte hier sollen anders ticken
als wir es ansonsten kennen doch was
genau steckt hinter dem spuk ihr habt
euch dieses mysteriöse thema bei
whatsapp gewünschte bekommt jetzt alle
wichtigen facts zum sogenannten
wunderwerk am alpenrand danke für eure
themenvorschlag und herzlich willkommen
bei klicks um science and fidget und wir
jetzt übrigens auch zusätzlich mit
telegramm inserm facebook natürlich wie
bisher auch mit whatsapp dabei sein
können das erfahrt ihr am ende des
videos
es gibt so einige mysteriöse orte auf
dieser welt beispielsweise das bermuda
dreieck im atlantik dort sollen sich
flugzeuge und schiffe einfach so in luft
auflösen auch aber auch am untersberg in
der nähe von bestes gaben sollen
menschen immer mal wieder auf
unerklärliche art und weise verschwinden
beispielsweise soll mal ein jäger ein
ganzes jahr verschwunden gewesen sein um
dann zu seinem eigenen trauer
gottesdienst wieder aufzutauchen oder
aber die sage nach der sich mitte august
immer wieder eine geheime stelle des
berges öffnen soll ein zeitloch das in
eine spiegel welt führt darin lebt der
mythos nach seit bereits 1000 jahren
kaiser karl der große und herrscht über
zwerge adlige und ritter die zeit in den
höhlen des berges soll 300 mal langsamer
vorbeigehen als in der realen welt
außerdem erzählt man sich auch die sage
der sogenannten untersberg aus einer
anderen welt sie tauchen einfach so im
hier und jetzt auf beispielsweise in den
14 kirchen des untersberg so erzählt es
die legende eines baumes der bei einem
gottesdienstbesuch es erstaunt war dass
er niemand der anderen besucher erkannte
kein wunder denn es handelte sich bei
den fremden leuten um die untersberg
klar aber es sind nicht nur die sagen
und mythen die den untersberg als einen
ganz besonderen berg mit zeit löchern
und spiegel welt
auf beschwerden die einwohner der region
nennen ihn den wunder berg und der dalai
lama selbst bezeichnet ihn als herz
chakra von europa es könnte also
wirklich etwas dran sein wenn man das
hört dabei ist der untersberg auch
geografisch gesehen nicht zu verachten
er ist 1972 meter hoch sein gebirgszug
erstreckt sich auf 70 quadratkilometer
und der untersberg ist nicht zuletzt
auch für das längste höhlensystem
deutschlands bekannt zwei drittel des
untersberg liegen in bayern die grenze
zu österreich verläuft durch seinen
nördlichen teil der fakt ist gefühlt
lebt die gesamte region dort von
angeblichen wundern und besonderen
energiefeldern am untersberg nirgendwo
sonst in oberbayern sind wohl so viele
esoteriker unterwegs wie hier einige
sind als alten schamane unterwegs und
machen führungen sie glauben daran dass
der untersberg eine art prophet für die
restliche welt ist so habe es
beispielsweise als eine vorwarnung für
das schwere himalaya erdbeben auch am
untersberg einen absturz gegeben zudem
hatte sich durch das geröll das wasser
des angrenzenden weiß bares rot gefärbt
auch das ein zeichen ebenso wie kurz vor
beginn des zweiten weltkriegs als ich
hier in der region der himmel rot
gefärbt hatte nach ansicht der
esoteriker vor ort eine prophezeiung
darauf dass der russlandfeldzug blutig
enden wird
die allumfassende erklärung der
esoteriker auf der erde sei alles mit
allem verbunden und der untersberg gebe
das wieder was auf der anderen seite der
welt passiert und in dieser region des
berchtesgadener landes sind es nicht
gerade wenige leute die an solche
theorien glauben und daran festhalten an
zufälle glaubt hier keiner
ebenso wenig was die unfälle von
höhlenforschern angeht im jahr 2014
wurde ein bekannter höhlenforscher in
950 metern tiefe von einem stein am kopf
getroffen seine rettung war durchaus
spektakulär sie dauerte und neun tage
und der forscher überlebte tatsächlich
das ist für viele ein wunder und
schicksal ist dann der zweite unfall
fast exakt ein jahr später
da wurde nämlich eine der leiterinnen
von einem stein erschlagen viele denken
dies liege an dem vorherigen ereignis
das energetische spuren hinterlassen
habe und schließlich wusste doch jeder
dass man den dauerkonflikten auf gar
keinen fall betreten sollte es gibt
sogar ein buch autor der eine buchreihe
veröffentlicht hat eine ganze buchreihe
gefüllt mit wunderlichen geschichten zum
untersberg wolfgang stadler hat seiner
ansicht nach schon selbst die wunder des
untersberg verfahren beispielsweise war
selbst schon einmal in einem zeit noch
gefangen so sagt der vormittags hatte er
eine höhle einen besuch abgestattet als
er wieder rauskam war es plötzlich abend
und auch dunkel der berg ist für ihn
eine riesige zeitmaschine dazu stadler
in einem interview zitat ich bin ein
gelernter techniker und glaube nur was
ich sehen kann
mittlerweile habe ich aber soviel
unfassbares erlebt dass ich völlig offen
bin für alles mystische seine lesung
jedenfalls sind super besucht und
stadler ist überzeugt davon dass seine
geschichten wahr sind und so seit
mittlerweile auch der geheimdienst
hinter ihm her
jetzt wird es aber sagen wir mal etwas
seltsam fest steht jedenfalls die oft
gruselig anmutenden geschichten vom
verschwundenen menschen haben sehr oft
ganz einfache gründe beispielsweise
waren in den 90er jahren mal ein ehepaar
und eine freundin als vermisst gemeldet
worden
sie sollen in ein zeitloch gefallen sein
so die befürchtung am ende stellte sich
dann heraus dass sie niemals am
untersberg war sondern auf einem schiff
im roten meer
dazu kommt forschungsteams weltweit
halten zeit löcher auf der erde die in
anderen dimensionen führen für komplett
abwegig es scheint also alles ein wenig
unterirdisch zu sein also abwegig was so
über den untersberg erzählt sorry wenn
ich da enttäuschen muss wenn er als
erstes neues zu mythen und geheimnissen
und zu allen anderen themen erfahren
wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer
hierbei whatsapp oder den anderen
messengern wie instagram facebook oder
telegramm dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor
allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert und täglich ihr könnt dort
direkt über mich in der redaktion von
klicks und mitmachen mitbestimmen was
ihr bei pixum passiert und zur begrüßung
gibt es noch ein kleines goodie einfach
hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht
das abo mit der genau mit der glocke
vergessen hier geht es weiter mit darf
auch draufklicken mythen legenden und
spekulationen die acht spannenden
pyramiden fakten
sonst bis dann bleibt dran